bonjour merci d'être en direct avec son
frère tu es français ce que le débat est
clos est ce que vous êtes rassurés par
les propos du patron français de sanofi
non j'ai écouté attentivement les les
propos qui ont été tenus et ses propos
ils disent que un vaccin bien sûr serait
accessible à tous mais serait d'abord
donné en priorité aux américains et je
considère que sanofi en tout cas n'a pas
inventé le vaccin contre l'indécence
je vous rappelle que sanofi c'est quand
même un groupe qui touche 1,5 qui a
touché les 10 dernières années 1 5
milliard d'euros de fonds publics liés à
ce qu'on appelle le crédit impôt
recherche qui l'année dernière a encore
gagné près de 25 millions d'euros du cic
eux qui sont aussi des fonds publics est
donc tout ça devrait conduire quand même
quand on a financé très largement par
l'argent public la recherche de sanofi à
ce que les français puissent disposer en
priorité de ce vaccin sanofi est un
groupe français ses revenus en france
dépense independent à 80% des revenus de
des ressources et des dépenses de la
sécurité sociale
vous voyez bien ça peut pas être le
public qui paye compte c'est compliqué
et puis ensuite il n'y a plus aucun coup
aucune contrepartie dans le fait que la
france puisse disposer de ce vaccin dont
je considère que la polémique n'est pas
close il suffit pas de dire que tout le
monde il y aura accès ensuite il suffit
seulement de dire que c'est qu'il n'y
aura pas de priorité aux américains et
je considère que les propos du
gouvernement sur le sujet sont ce des
protestations et qui aujourd'hui ne
suffisent pas donc j'attends de voir ce
que va faire le gouvernement pour faire
respecter la souveraineté puisque
monsieur macro nous dit maintenant que
la souveraineté doit être une priorité
que va-t-il faire concrètement pour
faire en sorte que la france puisse
disposer de sa propre capacité de
production de médicaments donc pourvoir
laboratoire français doit privilégier
avant tout son pays d'origine mais en
tout cas il doit faire en sorte que ça
soit pas d'autres b qu'ils soient
privilégiés au détriment de la france je
rappelle que c'est un laboratoire
français que nous payons par des fonds
publics
la recherche de sanofi et on voit bien
toutes là toute la difficulté dans cette
situation de d'avoir laissé pendant des
années faire en sorte que d'eau notre
autonomie sur des secteurs
stratégiques soient bafoués c'est que
quand on en a besoin et ben on se rend
compte qu'on peut plus compter sur sûr
c'est sur ces acteurs là
donc moi je crois que ce qui est à
l'ordre du jour c'est pas seulement des
protestations comme le fait le
gouvernement c'est le fait de décider de
reconstituer ou de constituer en france
un pôle public du médicament qui sont en
capacité de fournir des médicaments à la
population française quand elle en a
besoin parce qu'elle révèle finalement à
vos yeux cette polémique des enjeux
stratégiques sanitaire économique
je crois que ce qu'elle révèle c'est que
sur les secteurs les plus stratégiques
on ne peut pas faire confiance aux
marchés et à la cupidité de quelques
actionnaires je vous rappelle quand même
que pendant cette crise sanofi vient
d'annoncer qu'elle a versé 4 milliards
d'euros de dividendes et donc à la
profiter de la crise et je crois qu'elle
devrait être mise à contribution de
manière exceptionnelle l'escale révèle
c'est que on ne peut pas faire confiance
à des acteurs qui recherchent le profit
pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse être
fourni sur des secteurs qui sont des
secteurs stratégiques comme celui de la
production de médicaments et donc on a
besoin d'une entité publique un pôle
public du médicament qui fait que quand
on est confronté à des situations comme
celle dans laquelle on est aujourd'hui
on est les capacités de production en
médicaments qui nous permet de fournir
la population sans faire primer la
volonté de quelques actionnaires
au-delà de la question 1 du profit si on
se réfère aux déclarations de sanofi
france ce matin l'union européenne ne
serait pas aussi efficace en ce moment
que les états unis comment est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer ce retard français
alors bon c'est sûr que l'union
européenne en termes de recherche sur le
vaccin aujourd'hui n'a pas été à la
hauteur de la situation le nez c'est dix
coloris dont on a beaucoup parlé le
président de la république est
malheureusement un fiasco mais néanmoins
faut pas non plus tomber dans le
chantage qui essaye de faire sanofi
aujourd'hui sanofi s'appuie pour cela
sur le fait que 30 millions d'euros ont
été fournies par les états unis
d'amérique vient en fait un laboratoire
public qui a noué un partenariat avec
sanofi mais c'est 30 millions d'euros
c'est rien par rapport au 1,25 milliard
d'euros dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure qui est ce que l'état français a
fourni hassan au pied à travers
le crédit impôt recherche donc bien sûr
que l'union européenne allait pas à la
hauteur de la situation
mais le chantage de sanofi qui vise à
dire que parce que le les états unis
auraient fourni davantage d'argent c'est
eux qui pourrait disposer en priorité de
ce vaccin est un chantage tout à fait
indécent puisqu'il correspond pas du
tout à la réalité
voilà moi j'appelle à ce qu'on constitue
ce pôle public du médicament que s'il ne
sanofi ne revienne pas sur ses décisions
envisagées compris sa nationalisation
parce que c'est un secteur stratégique
et qui doit être sous le contrôle d'un
état de la puissance publique
c'est comme ça qu'on peut faire en sorte
qu'on sera pas dépendant de des intérêts
financiers de quelques entreprises
privées qui encore une fois ont été
largement financée par les fonds publics
merci pour cette réaction manuel bompard
je rappelle que vous êtes est député
européen chef de file de la délégation
de la france
un sommet au parlement européen